I always plan to do this this was like
my life goal
I play baseball basketball football
hockey soccer everything I literally
every morning I ate sports for breakfast
I wanted to be a professional athlete
and then of course I cap down at five
nine hundred fifty pounds and I realized
that career was going to end pretty
quick there was a boys club and I went
down the very first time I went there
there was a hardwood floor there
basketball court indoor basketball court
I'd never actually played on one that
just started to shoot baskets whenever I
went in I saw that hardwood floor and I
don't know what it is to this day I can
envision it as though it's right in
front of me it was actually after
watching the movie Jerry Maguire with
Tom Cruise where I realized wow there's
this whole other side of the business
sports was a huge part of my life
growing up my family
I saw what it meant to go to a sporting
event and how the experience of sharing
the game together with other people
could bring you together even across
socio-economic lines and I really love
that kind of fell in love with that
fandom I didn't know where to start and
at the time a lot of my friends and
classmates were interviewing for these
Wall Street jobs and so I went on one of
the interviews and was very quickly
romanced by this whole notion of being
on Wall Street and doing deals but it
was during that time that I had a
childhood friend who was killed in a car
accident and if he were here now I think
he would say I did I did what I wanted
to do I figured out who I was and I
pursued those things at that moment I
kind of made a very about-face shift in
the way that I approached my career and
I guess myself
you have to do something you care about
something you have passion for it's like
yeah I didn't wake up one day and say oh
I really want to be an investment banker
or something like that it's like hey
follow your dreams
every day Showtime and It's Showtime for
the players when they look at you in the
locker room when they look at you in the
canteen It's Showtime when you're on
camera and sometimes you have to in some
sense fake a little bit of Showtime
displaying weakness is not a good thing
it's so even if you're not confident act
confident I was confident I was very
confident that we could do it that we
could turn it around that we could win a
championship and that we could be
successful in every way you got to keep
the whole team motivated you got to keep
the whole team feeling like we're gonna
get this done we're gonna accomplish
this building a stadium in California is
a difficult exercise even though there
was one of those fifty or a hundred
times where I was worried are we gonna
be able to get this done are we gonna
overcome this hurdle I had to be
positive and I had to always exude
complete confidence that we were going
to get it done because if people didn't
see it me then how they can be confident
in themselves and what they're doing
it's absolutely paramount I'm passionate
about it because I want to win and
winning means a lot of different things
to me perhaps but for those underneath
you that you've got to keep that passion
although to be honest with you if you're
gonna come work for us it's 365 24/7 I
mean it's all the time because that's
who we are that's what we are and we're
all in we are out there on the streets
meaning people knowing their names
showing them that we know who they are
by name and that we really appreciate
their support we serve them we have a
duty to them
Oh them big for me that's what I love
you know I love being out there being
that person who's you know kind of the
Pied Piper making everyone you know
excited about what we're doing in
advancing the business and really making
it a success
what success means and how important
different things are completely
different for every single stakeholder
in the in the ecosystem the one thing
that actually coach Walsh used to say
and many years ago but it's stuck with
me every time is that when things are
good and they're praising you you're
never as good as they say you are and
when things are bad and they're
criticizing you you're never as bad as
they say you are this is an industry
sort of like the entertainment industry
but even more than the entertainment
industry you're making decisions in a
fishbowl and everybody's got an opinion
whether it's with facts or without facts
and they will state that opinion in
sometimes a measured way sometimes in an
obnoxious way if you can't take the heat
go find another industry can't take
stuff personally and you got to make
decisions quickly
but like the personal thing is a big
deal because you're having these
interactions and if you just get bogged
down and like oh my god I can't believe
that person said that or whatever and
you get kind of retaliatory it's totally
ineffective how do you make tough
decisions that the public doesn't
necessarily understand or agree with and
I think that's what leadership is they
don't have all the facts we're supposed
to have all the facts right and we're
supposed to be able to analyze them
correctly that is what we are supposed
to do you will be praised sometimes and
you will be booed sometimes and it's
really how you handle the situation that
is distinctive about leadership and also
about how the fans are gonna view you
Monta Ellis who's our most popular
player this is really only a year and a
half into our ownership and he was our
best player our most popular player in
fact honestly I was close to him and his
wife and I really loved how hard he
played having said that we had a plan it
involved a style of play and organizing
architecting a team work they structured
for our team which we thought would lead
to success in the NBA and that had to do
with defense first prototypical size at
every position and it had to do with a
fast-paced style of play so akin to the
Celtics of the 60s where I grew up is
where it comes from
defensive orientation led by Bill
Russell the 80s Showtime Lakers I lived
in LA during that period so the two
greatest influences for me in basketball
and so I didn't think we could survive
we didn't think we could survive with
two small guards even no matter how good
they were we banked on Steph Curry as
the cornerstone of our franchise he is
now of the 12 15 players on a roster the
only remaining player from that original
team five years ago so that trade for
Andrew Bogut a center the only way
you're going to get a big great Center
like that for a small guy is if he's
injured or something like that so we
took that risk people didn't understand
that at the time I knew they wouldn't I
didn't think I'd get booed I did by
20,000 people and we could talk about
that the effects of that as well but to
go from good to great is not an easy
thing to do
and if it was easy anyone could do it so
you have to make some tough decisions
and we made a tough decision to go out
and get the coach the last piece if you
will
adding to the roster that we had
assembled which was Steve Kerr who we
thought could finally put together not
the roster and have it play fully fully
in the type of style of type of play
that we wanted to play going forward
that could win a championship I think
when general a cub got booed in the
retiring the jersey the immediate
reaction was very negative but he really
handled that brilliantly in terms of the
next day he was on the radio talkback
radio responding to press and it turned
out that the train actually was a very
good trait that actually was a hallmark
of his management talents you know the
great thing about being booed or
something like that something something
really bad happened to you is that if
you then succeed you look really good I
think failure is really important you
need to fail at some point you need to
know what it feels like how horrible it
feels to fail to not succeed to be
criticized and then you know you were
able to take it the next time I had a
very good idea when we bought a team how
we were gonna run the team what the kind
of players that culture how we're gonna
design ourselves of the vision for the
basketball part for the business part
and I've been an owner the Celtics for
six years I've seen how the NBA runs I
thought about it for a long long time so
and I was a fan by the way
every fan thinks they know how to do it
better I thought I could do it better
too and in this case fortunately I was
able to do it better it's a challenging
time for the 49ers given that we were
coming off a lot of success we opened a
building and Levi's Stadium and the team
is from wins and losses standpoint takes
a dip a lot of people would just tell
you may be that there is some antidote
out there that they say now you gotta
have a thick shell and that it never
bothers them I can't make that statement
I was very much a minority I didn't play
college or NFL football so I was viewed
skeptically publicly and inside the
building and so when the team did poorly
then of course I was criticized
just the experience of having gone
through it sort of hardens you a little
bit more to it and to the point where
you just sort of get used to it I guess
but I'll tell you it comes down to the
challenge the thing that motivates me it
inspires me is trying to accomplish a
new challenge to see you I was not going
to be a long term owner understands that
his job is episodic
there will be episodes at which he may
be in a role as a CEO there may be
episodes in which he's been a role in
business development given the long time
periods often to get stadiums up you
have to have a perception of confidence
maybe audacity to sort of say this
challenge is in fact doable and people
have to ask me of what percent chance do
you think this thing's gonna work is it
like 10 percent
I always said it's 100 percent it's a
100 percent going to work because you
have to almost convince yourself and
rationalize that hey this is such a
complicated and difficult thing but we
need to find a way to power through to
motivate your team we wanted to build
one of the best stadiums in all Major
League Soccer or the world wanted to
build it here in Silicon Valley with an
innovative great fan experience and we
wanted to put a team in there that was
gonna compete for championships with the
earthquakes when we were building the
stadium and we had to delay it another
year because we found issues with the
site itself because this was an old tank
factory so there was bunkers and
underground vaults and then the
community group had opposed it here in
San Jose so we had to go through to Pele
and the community here is like are you
ever gonna build the stadium and I'm the
kind of a front person of this entire
thing and so that was really hard to
manage there was hard to convince my
staff to follow me through that really
difficult time but I think at the end of
the day we had a clear vision of what we
wanted to do when we were at Candlestick
Park we just weren't able to compete
economically with some of the teams that
had newer stadiums the effort to build
Stadium that was a six eight ten year
effort of finding the right place to do
it working with the municipality
financing marketing selling designing
the stadium all of that and it was a 1.3
billion dollar stadium
what we call the in stadium experience
is something that is is going under a
lot of transformation how does the in
stadium environment compete with the
couch
it's really great to watch the NFL from
your couch the picture is great it's
easy to follow the game the concessions
are a lot cheaper the bathroom is a lot
cleaner it's easier to get to and it
takes three and a half hours instead of
five and a half hours hockey more than
any other major sport there is no
question about it the live experience is
paramount the home experience the TV
experience cannot compete with the live
experience and so as things become more
accessible on-demand
that live experience creates even more
of a premium it used to be one end of
the spectrum was the at-home experience
the other end of the spectrum was the
add stadium experience and what we're
seeing now is the morphing of the two so
what goes on in the stadium is
attempting to address what are some of
the benefits at home whether it's quick
delivery of foods no lines for the
bathroom availability of replace so all
the stadiums are try to design
themselves so that they're a lot more
flexible for the entertainment
experience that's another customer
ittsan or what it means to be a fan what
does a fan really want is a fan want
Wi-Fi or does they want an actual app
that enables you to get in the stadium
quicker and find out where the restrooms
are where the food is who wants the app
isn't care what the Wi-Fi so I think a
lot of times stadiums are built there
just checking all these boxes in terms
of like oh it has the fastest Wi-Fi or
it has you know the nicest of the seats
what people really want is the
experiences that's why they pay top
dollar for these things and so when I
really look at what we do with the
stadium is we were very experiential
driven it's a very big business and you
know these teams have really started to
proliferate in terms of asset value as
you've seen certainly in the last five
or six years and that's because you're
seeing these teams being run like
efficient businesses much more so than
you did a decade ago
don't mistake that these are real
businesses that require hard skills and
to the extent that you can demonstrate
that you have those hard skills I think
you can really differentiate yourself
you can't just find their way through
because you love Michael Jordan it's
just not enough a lot of times when
people talk about analytics they're
really only talking about on the field
on the court on the ice but there's also
the business side of analytics that is
has also taken off in sports you know
traditional industries have been doing
it for a hundred years and Sports really
has only been focused on it over the
last decade or so and I'm talking about
measuring the lifetime value of a
customer understanding how to market to
your fans understand how to price your
building understanding new opportunities
to what businesses you might enter how
you do your merchandising all of those
things Hawking lagged behind the other
leagues in this idea of numbers driven
analytics driven decision making there
was kind of a lot of white space to play
of course there's risk there too it's
easier to go into an environment where
there's other people like you it's
harder to be on the on the leading edge
but I I was excited by that that white
space I would say most people probably
looked at me and said he's a little bit
of a gut shooter maybe not as analytical
I think that's actually totally not true
I think the truth is that I'm very
analytical I believe very much in the
data get the data analyze the data work
speedily it's an entrepreneurial kind of
attitude about our organization the way
we run our business we encourage very
strong debate but then it's my job make
the decision I certainly listen most of
the time to what the group decides and
then we just do it and we go so I do
think that is what's different that's
what separates that's the Silicon Valley
way the entrepreneur way that is not the
big company way and I think that I have
gotten from being in the valley for
30-some odd years I have an
entrepreneurial background for me that's
weak you know as exciting the challenge
the fact that we are a challenger that
it's hard for me
soccer is kind of a perfect sport
because it's not figured out yet the
United States we're kind of the young
Hiep energized or that's connected to
the Millenial and the generation see the
younger folks and I think as the country
continues to change and kind of there's
almost a new America that's coming with
you know people who are more
international and global in their focus
this can be the sport for them for the
broader community of a sports world
people kind of know that and they sense
it's coming and so they want to be a
part of the growth and the excitement of
what that means it is absolutely in
every sense of the word a startup and
we've had all the same ups and downs
roller coasters
that's what the last year-and-a-half
starting this has been like we sold out
our opening night game turns out it was
the hottest day in San Diego like ever
the building is really hot around game
time you start to see the kind of ice
start melting fog starts rising by the
middle of the first period we were
actually stopping the game
intermittently to let the fog rise so
that the players could see just never in
a million years do we plan for fog I
think this is just a good kind of
archetype of the way we try to operate
as a start-up with each success or with
with each failure I'm energized by the
opportunity to grow and do better
I only have two jobs so I like to say
one is to create a vision for the
organization and two is hire the very
best people you could possibly hire have
them hire the best people they can hire
under them that's you know management
101 and let them do their jobs having
great guys great women great character
out there matters when the chips are
down and things aren't going well you
want someone who's out there who's smart
who's a good teammate all those things
matter if it's not there the other sense
it and it's not gonna go well there
isn't one person on our team that I
wouldn't want to go to dinner with or
have my kids hang out with and you know
what here's another thing from a
business perspective if you're a fan who
do you want to go pay to see play it's
not just the players that are really
good at what they do but people you can
believe in
Steph Curry of course is the ultimate in
this regard and the culture we created
ear and the head coach we have in
Dominic Kinnear it is focused on the
team as opposed to just individual
players and I think that culture is
attractive to a lot of fans that's the
type of the ethos we want team first do
it means something there's integrity
there's values associated with it in
this day and age in sports a lot of
that's been lost
the really good managers make the time
and make the effort to really understand
how the pieces come together and it's
manageable but a lot of people don't do
it because they think it's beneath them
there is this misguided in my opinion
idea and this drives me crazy
oh well that owner should stay out of
the way he should not meddle but this
idea of meddling is is just wrong what
they should be saying is micromanagement
is a bad thing let people do their jobs
stay out of the way but meddling implies
that you're trying to get information or
be involved in all the different areas
of the business and that's not a good
thing
I believe exactly the opposite any small
business and this is really small
business this is not you know mega
corporation the leader the owner they
should be involved in everything they
should know what's going on they're
gonna do a better job they should know
their fan base they should know all the
numbers they should know all the people
that work there they should know the
players they should understand the
implications of a trade of assets I've
had a very open and transparent
management style with everyone
associated with the club fans players
front office employees ownership anyone
and one way that's really manifested
itself is that every Tuesday from 3 to 5
I've office hours and people anyone can
come in off the street and talk to me
about any concerns they have I've met
with people who you know want me to buy
insurance I've had with people who want
a job I met with folks who just want to
talk about how their father loved the
earthquakes back in 1976 and so it's a
wide variety of interactions and it
keeps me connected with the pulse of the
team when you're building culture you
have to have actual things people can
point to like almost like a lighthouse
like my office hours have become a
lighthouse for people to understand what
our culture is it's like if Dave cattle
the president of the earth base will
meet with anyone at any time if I'm in
fan relations and I tell a person who
I'm selling tickets to no I'm not gonna
meet with you doesn't jive up I try to
spend time working with people at every
level
in turn straight team mascot all the way
up to the senior leaders of our
organization I work hand in hand with
them at their job whenever I can
I'll count merchandise I'll balance the
cash register I'm up there with our
play-by-play guy I will spend time on
the headset kind of calling the game I
answer every email that I get and so
there is nothing that I would ask
someone to do on our team that I
wouldn't do myself and they know that
not because I say it but because I do it
you got to be all in there is no way to
kind of have one foot in the canoe
you're always kind of connected to
what's happening in your role as the
president of the earthquakes it's just
part of who you are it's very connected
to your identity and that's just the
only way to do it and be successful
because like I said if you're really
trying to kind of have one foot in the
canoe it's very hard to find success and
I think that the strain that creates is
just not something that's healthy for me
I think the change sort of came when
when my wife and I found out we were
pregnant my career and my job for at
that point 14 years or 15 years and at
the 49ers it defined who I was like I
was my job and you know I lived it in
the same way I ate sports for breakfast
when I was a kid like that's just what I
did it was it was who I was and then
certainly when juniper was born I
realized that the job is just what I do
and who I am is is a father and a
husband and being at home it really sort
of hit me like an epiphany
I had combined those two for so long and
now there's a clear separation that
hasn't changed my passionate work but it
certainly changed me
they want to see passion they want to
see energy but they don't want to see
obsession because obsession can become
too narrow in the sense of when you lose
which every team does that everybody
gets devastated the idea is to make the
Loews less and keep some of the 404 the
high I think that's the real art of
Management in the spring
when you're riding so high the biggest
dangerous complacency that you accept
the fact that you are number one and
believe that there's not much to stop
you from being number one that's not
true I mean horse racing thought that
boxing thought that look where they are
now so I think you have to be forever
vigilant and also seek new mountains
each experience fills me with this
desire to do it again do it differently
repeat our success I never sit back at
the end of the night and say well we won
two to nothing and we did XYZ in
attendance and I feel great
frankly I wish I could do that a little
bit more but I just I recognize things
and see opportunities and there's so
much left to do there's so much of the
story yet to be written
you'll have a nice run of success and
you'll have your droughts and you just
have to continue to plant the seeds
during the drought hoping that when they
do blossom again that they blossom for a
long time
I feel a great sense of pride and what
we build here because it was something
that when I came here in 2010 this
wasn't necessarily just going to happen
and so when I look at the stadium behind
me and I think about the team we've
created that brings a smile to my face
thinking about it because it was really
hard and we did find success now we can
focus on a lot of these second-order
issues like getting great young talent
and developing American players and
winning another MLS championship over
the last five years we just had to pull
ourselves up to that point so we can
even have this conversation but for us
we're super excited to be able to take
that next step maybe some people would
be satisfied they won the championship
they're done move on to the next thing
the thing is I think the great task for
me right now and for us is
sustainability can we do it again and
maybe even again and again can we be
continually great can we be good for a
long time that's the real test can you
be good for a long time I think we can
ah
victorious victorious
Victoria's sorry
Anisa comes out
family be creative town
the waste of my time on crazy letting
write your opinion destroy you while
just embracing that what a worldly
sunrise your daylight savings go nuts
when the head to glaze bet my cell in
this reason else that we dream it must
be way back up in there guess who my
cousin is
record God's Way
become a denominator solo try to work or
a [ __ ]
so me cuz I got no competition
looking at all your
a formality engine trouble look arrival
Oh eyes on me cuz I got no competition
I know your
to be
want to be
and to be arias
yes